The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Audio quality for this video
is poor due to technical
difficulties.
PROFESSOR: OK, today, political
barriers to
educational change.
"One had to cram all this stuff
into one's mind, whether
one liked it or not.
This coercion had such a
determined effect that after I
had passed the final examination
I found the
consideration of any
scientific problems
distasteful to me for an entire
year." Who said that?
Einstein, so one of the greatest
scientists in the
last 300 or 400 years.
So that was the effect of
regular school and education
on Einstein.
And it's not just Einstein.
It's a general pattern.
So here, from Manchester, New
Hampshire, in the 1930's is
how Bruce [? Betiset ?]
superintendent describes the
children's approach to learning
and to reading and
interest in knowledge.
"In the traditional fourth
grades, when I asked children
to tell me what they'd been
reading, they were hesitant,
embarrassed, and diffident.
In one fourth grade I cannot
find a single child who would
admit that he had committed
the sin of reading.
I did not have single volunteer
and when I tried to
draft them, the children
stood up, shook
their heads, sat down.
In the four experimental fourth
grades the children
fairly fought to tell me what
they had been reading.
The hour closed-- in each case--
with a dozen hands
waved in the and little faces
crestfallen because we had not
got around to hear what
they had to tell."
So the contrast is
pretty strong.
And the question is why do
experiments like what
[? Betiset ?] did not survive?
Whereas why does the education
system tend to have an effect
such as Einstein described,
where he found the
consideration of any
scientific problems
distasteful an entire year?
So reading is a particular
example-- which I'll give you
another one [INAUDIBLE]--
of the change and the
effect of the
formal educational system.
So in revolutionary America--
so this is late 1770's--
Thomas Paine's Common Sense
sold 120,000 copies.
And their population then
was three million.
OK, so that's 1/100th of
the population now.
So the equivalent of 120,000
copies then was about 10
million or 12 million
copies today.
Now if you actually look at
Thomas Paine's Common Sense,
it's written in a language,
today, that we
would call very biblical.
When we read it you use English
and we speak English
but you wouldn't expect 12
million people to buy a book
of that complexity
and subtlety.
Now that expectation's is
confirmed by many a study
about literacy and proficiency
in analyzing documents
conducted across the
United States.
So the latest one, it was in
2003, National Assessment of
Adult Literacy.
So this was published in 2005
by the US government.
So they America in 2003 and
they tested three kinds of
proficiencies.
Prose proficiency, which is
comparing viewpoints and two
editorials as an example of
something where if you have
prose proficiency you have
document proficiency, which is
interpreting a table about
blood pressure and any
physical activity.
So taking information from
doctors and [INAUDIBLE].
And quantitative proficiency,
computing and comparing the
cost and analysis
of food items.
But none of these are very
advanced skills.
OK now, the percentage of adults
who are proficient in
each of these categories?
13%.
OK, now, 13% is a very, very
low number especially
considering the level of
proficiency that's required,
the threshold is pretty low.
Whereas back in 1770's America
10 million, 12 million people
equivalent today bought Thomas
Paine's Common Sense.
And probably many of them were
not actually literate in the
sense that they couldn't read.
So that book was read to them.
So there was a great hunger
for words and ideas and
learning, which in many ways we
had not matched, despite or
because of the vast extent of
the schooling system and
educational system.
So suppose you want
to change this.
You want to improve
the situation.
You'd like to make
education better.
What are some of
the obstacles?
So I'm going to discuss the
obstacles in ascending order
of difficulty in overcoming.
So another way to phrase,
ascending order of
how local they are.
So the first obstacle I'm going
to discuss is one that's
local to personal psychology.
It's local to how people
individually act.
And then I'll move
to obstacles that
are broader in scope.
So the first obstacle is what
I'll call cognitive
dissonance.
So the way to see this in action
is suppose you go to
someone and you say, well you
know, the way that that course
is done could really
be improved if
you do it this way.
And you think you've made a
perfectly reasonable point,
perfectly valid point.
But somehow your point isn't
taken any notice of.
Or it's met with resistance
and maybe even hostility.
Now, why might that be?
Well, there are many reasons.
But one of them is you might
have phrased it badly.
You might have cursed out
somebody's mother while you
were doing it.
There are all kinds of things
that you have a lot of control
over and don't necessarily
have to do.
But there are some reasons that
are harder to control.
And that's in the psychology
of the person who's hearing
what you're saying.
So one of the obstacles is
this idea of cognitive
dissonance.
So let's see how that works.
So cognitive dissonance was a
concept invented in the 1950's
by Festinger, Leon Festinger,
psychology at Stanford.
And he did the following
experiments.
The experiments were, he had
people come and do this task
where they basically just put
round pegs into round holes
and-- he's a college student--
put square pegs into square
holes and triangle pegs
into triangle holes.
So after they did the experiment
they were then
split into two groups.
Group A was just sent away.
You know, they did the
experiment and they left and
nothing more was heard from
them until a year later.
Now Group B was told, oh, we
actually need people to help
us recruit more volunteers
for this experiment.
And obviously they might have
problems recruiting people to
do the experiment because
it was so dull.
All you do is put square
pegs into square holes.
So they said would you
be willing to be--
in the experiment--
our assistant in helping
recruit people?
So Group A, they
just went away.
And Group B, they were offered
a position as experimenter's
assistant and were paid
$20 for that.
And Group C-- the same thing.
They were offered a position as
experiment's assistant but
they were only paid $1.
This was in 1950-ish.
So roughly speaking in today's
dollars, let me
just translate those.
So here's a way of estimating
the equation.
So in 1950 we still have
the gold standard.
And the gold standard
was $35 an ounce.
So the world price of gold was
fixed by Fiat from Bretton
Woods at $35 an ounce.
Now it's maybe $70 an ounce.
So inflation is about 25%.
So this is about 400 today.
And this is about $20.
So then what happened was these
students then did their
work, nothing, this, or that,
being an assistant.
And then they were tested a year
later about their opinion
of the experiment.
So that was actually the
real experiment.
So these students thought--
like all psychology
experiments--
they were actually helping
recruit people for an
experiment.
When actually, they were
the experiment.
They were really the subject.
So a year later they were asked
their opinion of the
experiment, did you think
it was interesting?
So these people, they obviously
thought it was
boring because it
wasn't worth it.
So a year later these people
were asked what they thought.
And these people said boring.
OK, now, what about
Groups B and C?
What did they think?
So take a minute or two, try
to predict what they were
opinions about the experiment
were one year later.
Question, yes?
AUDIENCE: So did they have
a choice to participate?
Were they forced to do this?
PROFESSOR: No, I don't think
they were forced.
It was the Group B who
agreed, or the Group
C people who agreed.
I'm pretty sure that's right.
And I'm sure they
weren't forced.
So yeah, find a neighbor or
two and see if you can
predict, what did Groups B and
C think after a year or so?
OK, so, what do you think
they thought?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, maybe Group C
liked the experiment better
because they were only trying
to recruit, I think they
wanted to but [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so Group
C maybe liked it more.
So the question is,
who liked it more?
So maybe Group C
liked it more.
So they weren't getting enough
incentive in cash and they
must have liked it.
Any other thoughts, comments?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's possible
they didn't like it
originally, but they convinced
themselves they liked it
because they were doing this
work recruiting for not very
much money.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So they must have convinced
themselves because they were
getting enough cash
to be happy.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So did
[? all of them ?] take over?
Or are we talking only about
those who did it?
PROFESSOR: That I
don't remember.
That's a good question.
I think we're just talking
about the people
who took the offer.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it was
self selection?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's
some self selection.
AUDIENCE: But if a group came
from that, you probably should
ask the question immediately
after the experiment before
asking them to help assist and
then you set the control.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And they might
have done that.
I don't remember all
the details of it.
So they might have done that.
And [? some wonder ?] if the
control was the Group A. But
you're right, that's another
good control.
And they might have done that.
Other comments or questions?
Predictions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this a flat rate
or is this a per person?
PROFESSOR: Oh, per person
they recruited?
No, this was their salary.
Yeah, that'd be pretty
lucrative, $20 a pop.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was thinking B
probably wouldn't have liked
it as much as C because they
probably would have thought,
if they have to pay me $400 it's
really, really boring.
PROFESSOR: OK, so B liked it
less on the theory that they
were doing it just
for the money.
They were thinking
to themselves--
AUDIENCE: Or also if the reason
they really have to pay
them this much to get the
subjects it must really suck.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, and you can
look at it another way.
You can say, they're paying
me this much money.
There must be some intrinsic
importance to the work.
So you could convince
yourself--
PROFESSOR: it could
go both ways.
AUDIENCE: Right, exactly.
PROFESSOR: They pay me
a lot so it must be
really important work.
They must have tons of
government funding for people.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So it could be [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, comment?
AUDIENCE: Well, I have to say,
I think the process of
recruiting people would get
you to like it more.
Because you'd have
to be selling it.
And then the question is whether
you put more effort
into that if you're getting
paid more money or not.
PROFESSOR: OK, but the common
point is recruiting can help
you like it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so I would say
to me, actually, you were
right, actually, what happened
is that these people still
found this boring.
And these people liked it.
And basically, at the time this
was counter intuitive.
And the whole idea of cognitive
dissonance was built
up to explain this
counter-intuitive result,
which is why would you like it
more when you're paid less?
It is sort of counter
intuitive.
And it's exactly like you say,
which is that you reason to
yourself well, if they're giving
me 400, yeah, sure, I'd
sell my grandmother for 400.
You know, that doesn't mean
that I don't like my
grandmother.
But $400 is $400.
But if they only
give you $20--
that's option C--
no, of course you wouldn't
do that.
There must be some reason
that you're doing that.
So if you're participating in
the activity we'll say by
doing but don't like it,
or at least you try to
justify it to yourself.
You need some kind
of justification.
And the justification of Group
B is well, I'm doing it
because it pays a
lot of money.
The justification of Group C
can't be that because there
isn't enough money.
So it must be that it's an
intrinsically worthwhile activity.
So the opinion shifts.
Now if you remember, I mentioned
cognitive dissonance
as one of reasons to have
people vote when you're
originally doing multiple-choice
questions.
Give a muiltiple-choice question
to the students, say
A, B, C, or D. The importance of
having them vote and make a
public stand is that it commits
them to the question
and to the answer.
Now they have some public
appearance in the one of the
A, B, C, D categories.
And they want to know,
is this right?
So the political organizers
know this.
And these kind of ideas
are old hat now.
We've seen things that
consciousness and psychology
in marketing.
So people will sometimes-- for
example-- come around and ask
you well, would you mind putting
a sign in your front
yard for this political
campaign?
Well, at first they'll say,
would you like to give $100 to
the campaign?
And you say, no.
I don't really know
who XYZ is.
I sort of maybe support
him $100.
[INAUDIBLE].
So you say no.
They say, OK, well, would you
mind putting a sign in your
front yard?
So now, what have you done?
Made a public commitment.
All right, everybody who drives
by or walks by sees
that sign for the candidate.
So now studies are completely
consistent with this--
you now do it-- you now support
that candidate more.
So turns out, what's the key
thing in changing your view?
Is that you feel you
had a choice.
So here, if you put a gun to
someone's head and say, put a
sign in your front yard.
And they put a sign in their
front yard, that doesn't
change their view of
the candidate.
The person could
refuse or not.
It was up to them.
If they chose to do it, well,
that opens a door to further
commitment.
So here, this is sort of like
putting a gun to their head.
This is sort of like putting
a gun to their head.
You don't really feel like
you have a choice.
You're like, OK, whether it was
boring or not, who cares?
Whereas here, you
took the choice.
And the ones that did it
changed their view.
So cognitive dissonance is
very, very powerful.
Now, how does that relate to
peoples' response when you
say, you'd like to change
the course?
OK, and we'll come to that.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so again,
Group A then was
never offered a choice?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, they
were sent away.
And they were asked a year
later to see what
they thought of it.
And they said, yeah,
it was boring.
They're sort of control.
I mean, you expect them
to say, it's boring.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
boring?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, just to check
so no one could say, well,
maybe people found it
really fascinating.
You know, because they didn't.
So now what happens when you say
to someone, oh, we really
should change the way
this course is done.
So now suppose you're at some
weak university like MIT or
Cambridge or something
like that.
Now, where do a lot of the
people who teach at these
universities come from?
Either that same university--
especially in England, that was
really notorious in the
united justification [? for
it ?], which was that our
system's so wacky and different,
only people who've
been through that particular
system can
possibly teach here.
So how are the justifications?
Either the people come from that
same place or come from a
similar background, similar
university background.
So now you're not criticizing
a system that
they A, selected them.
Right?
The system selected them from
a whole bunch of people.
And so by definition, it
must be a good system.
Also, they've now had many
opportunities to make public
commitments to the system of the
way things are taught, the
way things are done.
They've taught them in classes,
they've participated
in curriculum discussions.
They've selected the students
that come, recommended the
students that would
be better or worse
according to that system.
So the result is that because
of years of cognitive
dissonance working on people,
they are now very, very
convinced that the way things
are done right now is great.
And although it's called
cognitive dissonance, it's not
necessarily a cognitive
belief.
If you ask them, can you explain
why it's great they
wouldn't necessarily give
you great reasons.
And this can be very misleading
and can lead you
into hot water.
So for example, when you say,
well, really we should teach
this course differently and put
in interactive questions
so students learn them.
You'll get responses that
are almost nonsense.
They'll be things like, for
example, well, if we don't put
everything on the chalkboard how
will students know what's
going to be on the exam?
And yeah, it's a valid
English sentence.
But it's not a good argument
because there are other ways
to communicate with students.
You can put stuff on notes.
You can say, read the book.
There's tons of answers
to that problem.
But these kind of things can be
offered as just a complete
trump card.
OK, these trumps have been
played, because no one can do
anything interactive.
Now, that level of thought
that's behind it, no way
people would put that level of
thought into their research
and be successful
with research.
And how come that's OK
and can be sort of
convincing in this area?
Well, because it's really
not a cognitive
response to be made.
It's a belief response.
You threaten and challenge a
person's core beliefs and
they're going to come out
and react very strongly.
And if you try to argue it just
on the rational level
you'll, actually, pick
up angry people.
And you won't anger yourself
because you wonder why you
hate the progress.
So one way to think about those
kinds of conversations
is A, if they're difficult
conversations--
and actually, the reason I write
that there is there's an
excellent book called Difficult
Conversations.
written by--
I'm pretty sure-- it's from the
Harvard Negotiation Project.
And they said, look, every
interaction-- and I
think this is right--
has three levels.
So that would be the factual
level, which is just the ideas
being exchanged, of should we
teach interactively or not?
Is there enough time?
There's the emotional level,
which is how we feel about
these facts.
And then there's the meaning.
So what does this discussion
mean for people?
So as an example, [INAUDIBLE],
the problem with a student
who's worried about
their grade.
Well, you can tell them,
factually, look--
about 3% on that problem set is
going to be 0.03% of your
grade's total points, don't
even worry about it.
All right, so that's
the factual level.
You may often find that just the
factual discussion is just
the tip of the iceberg
because there's all
this stuff going on.
So what could some
of this stuff be?
Well, the emotional level is
they just feel really anxious
about grades.
Now, why might that be?
Well, that's where the
meaning comes in.
The meaning may be that they
feel that the grade measures
how good they are.
And they've always thought they
got into MIT by mistake.
And now people are going
to find them out.
If they ever get a bad grade
their cover will be blown.
And everyone will know that
they don't belong.
So it may have a really strong
meaning for them, which is
rather emotional.
Which means the fact [INAUDIBLE]
discussion
[INAUDIBLE].
So it's a similar thing with
the discussion of change in
education, is that people will
have a factual discussion that
seems pointless and it's just
frustrating to you.
Because actually there's
emotional investment in the
way things are done.
And meaning, it means
a lot to people.
This system, it chose them.
It's a system they're
committed to.
And it's being criticized
by you.
Therefore, you're going to get
a whole bunch of unrealized
anger [INAUDIBLE].
Question?
AUDIENCE: So when it comes to
changing a single class and
adding some interactivity,
what are the downfalls
avoiding the difficult
conversations by asking for
forgiveness rather
than permission?
PROFESSOR: Nate, that's
a good question.
So asking for forgiveness rather
than permission, one of
the downsides is--
I think, in small and moderate
doses that is a good idea.
Because first of all, no
one's going to notice.
Because they're too busy with
their own [INAUDIBLE] teaching
that that's rather busybody
over what you're doing.
So you have, definitely,
something right away that you
might as well use.
But if you want to make any
larger changes, like for
example, take out something
that you think isn't so
important in the curriculums--
and make room for doing this--
and somebody downstream
really wants that.
Well, it's important to have
done it beforehand, discuss it
beforehand.
Because otherwise, if there's
emotional and meaning
investment in the way things are
done, they won't be able
to listen and then
you surprise them
with a factual change.
They won't be able to listen
to your factual arguments
then, because you activated the
emotional and meaning responses.
So you want to try to arrange,
[INAUDIBLE] those things
beforehand and get all those
out in the open first.
So I would say, for smaller
changes, yeah.
For larger changes, it's
important to have people
jointly figure out what to
do, which is true of
any political change.
And that's why when I
deliberately chose the title
Political Barriers to
Educational Change.
Because political barriers has
the implication that it's a
political problem.
It's a social problem.
It's a collective problem.
And any collective problems has
these issues of what you
do by yourself versus what we do
in a group or [INAUDIBLE].
Question, yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I'm just a little
bit confused about the idea of
cognitive dissonance.
So is that where the [INAUDIBLE]
between the
responses of groups B and C?
PROFESSOR: Mm-hmm.
Yes, it's that.
Oh, so where does the dissonance
come into it?
I should've explained that.
The dissonance is what
you try to reduce by
changing your view.
So in Group B there's really
no dissonance because the
experiment's boring.
And they did the recruiting
because they were paid.
There's no dissonance.
Here, the experiment is boring,
but they don't have
the resolution that oh, I'm
being paid to do it.
So they have to have some way
of reducing that dissonance.
And they're going out and
recruiting people.
So the way they do it is they
reduce the dissonance between
the internal view and external
performance by changing their
internal view.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering
whether--
do you know how people talk
about how sometimes if you're
trying to convince people to
do something you try to get
them to feel like it
was their idea?
And it seems like that would
be the opposite approach to
what you were just saying, which
was that you try to get
people on board in advance maybe
even so subtly that they
don't even realize it.
Because I think if you make
people feel like they're being
threatened and furthermore that
like you're deceiving
them, but they'll claim to be
always kind of on purpose
because you felt like you were
backed into a corner.
And even if they're not
committed to it, because it
produces them as [INAUDIBLE],
or just because people don't
like to be fooled, that they
don't like to feel like
they're taken advantage of.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's why I would
say, yeah.
Take advantage of the freedom
that you have that everyone
sort of [INAUDIBLE]
to make smaller changes
just on your own.
AUDIENCE: Do you have ideas
for how you might go about
[INAUDIBLE], if you see people
with [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And not so much convincing
things that
it's their idea it's--
yeah, I don't want to phrase it
as people think this as a
dishonest [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
PROFESSOR: It's really you're
trying to find collective
solutions to problems that you
both think are happening, or
you all think are happening.
So one way to go about that
is to say, well, look.
Here is a problem I see.
What do you think you
could do about it?
They might agree with
you on the problem.
By creating one problem, pretty
much generally people
will say, yeah, the students
are fine with problem set.
But when they have to go
do something with it,
they can't do it.
So you'll get a much wider
grievant on that statement
than on what to do about it.
But you can start there.
Say, OK, well, what do you think
we should do about it?
They may have some ideas.
They may accept the idea
that, well, this
is a serious problem.
And it's not clear what
to do about it.
But that right away gives you
some license to try to
[? external?]
[INAUDIBLE].
So you say, OK, well,
here's one thing
I'm thinking of trying.
Let's see how it works.
So you're not saying, it must be
done this way, and this is
the only way to do it, and
you're bad to not do it.
Say, well I'm going
to try this.
Let's see how it works.
And I'm happy to share
the results with you.
And you can use that, too.
And so there's another related
point to that, which is the--
I don't know what percentage
to give it.
So let's call it
a 10%, 10%, 8%.
So 10%, 10%, 8% equals this.
So 10% of people will
be early adopters.
They're really curious
about new things.
They want to try new things.
Let's call them [INAUDIBLE].
There will be, say, 10% who no
matter what you do are just
going to say, this
is terrible.
So, the never adopters.
And the 8% who are in the middle
who will wait to see
and will sort of sit
on the fence but
[INAUDIBLE], but open.
They have other priorities,
but they're open to
these kind of things.
So my rough rule of thumb is,
when you're talking to
someone, could be figure out
which category they're in.
If they're in- this is true of
political discussions, right?
You probably have some relatives
in the family where
you just agree we're not going
to talk about politics.
Right?
So, I have them.
I'm sure I'm in some people's
category of that , too.
We just say, we're just not
going to talk about that.
Because one or the two of us is
not going to adopt the view
of the other no matter what is
said because you just think
it's absurd.
So if someone's in that
category, don't
even spend any time.
Just spend your time
[INAUDIBLE]
category and say, OK, I'm
going to move on.
If they're in this category,
you usually can figure that
out pretty quickly, too.
Work with them.
And if they're in this category,
that's the people
you can reach if you do
things in a good way.
OK, now this is actually
pretty large.
I think in the '70s this was
called the silent majority,
was the code for this
[? this word. ?]
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are you ready
to be done with this?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk a
little bit-- maybe a little
later-- about what sort
of scale changes
you're talking about?
And also along with that, how
much power each individual
professor has to design
their own course.
If you figure out what the
prerequisites are for the next
course, then I don't see exactly
what the problem is
doing whatever you want in your
course as long as you
meet those-- as long
as you teach them.
PROFESSOR: So the question is
what size scale change am I
talking about?
Well, it depends.
How much freedom you
have depends on the
change you want to do.
For example, suppose you took to
heart some of the readings
that were for today and you
thought that grading was
really terrible and you want to
just dispense with grading
completely.
Well, even if you're teaching
all the right stuff, that will
raise a lot of of ire.
And people will come after you
for that even if you're
teaching everything right and
you're doing all the prereq.
Because it will trigger all
kinds of factual, emotional,
meaning responses
in other people.
And it'll go against many,
many-- and that's what I'm
going to talk about next is--
features of American society
to think we must
do things that way.
So you have less freedom to do
something like that, even if
you're meeting all
the prereqs.
Now, if you want to, for
example, use different
examples to teach the
same ideas, Everyone
wants complete freedom.
So it really depends what
you want to do.
Then there's many scales where
you can make change.
So you may find that there isn't
any way to do what I
want to do and meet all the
prereqs for the next course,
because it just means doing
way too much stuff.
OK, well now you have
a problem of a
bigger scale change.
How do you get the whole group
of faculty or group of people
in charge of that area or course
to change what was
going on and changes the
prerequisites, change the
overall curriculum.
So now, you're definitely going
to be working with lots
of other people.
There's another sort of
dichotomy, which is is the
course required or not?
If the course isn't required,
you have much more freedom.
[INAUDIBLE]
so your course.
If people don't like it, they
don't have to take it.
And even if other people don't
like your course or don't
think it's that important,
they're perfectly happy,
generally, to let you teach
the course that they don't
think is that important.
Because they want to teach their
course, which you may
think is not that important.
But now the required courses
that every single undergrad
that majors in the fields take,
those generally are
guarded more with jealousy.
And so changes in those are
harder and generally require
more consent from other people
just because it's considered a
shared core of the field.
So that's the meaning.
And by changing that, you're
complicitly perhaps
threatening to share
core of the field.
Does that answer
your question?
OK, so what I'm going to talk
about after the break--
so this was the idea
of cognitive
dissonance, and what role--
and maybe just a few, your
local group, maybe your
department, maybe
your school--
difficulties and obstacles and
issues that come up when
you're trying to make some kind
of educational change.
What I'm going to talk about
after the break is
society-wide features.
All right.
So American society or say,
European-American society in
general, that impose really
large obstacles
in educational change.
In some ways, even bigger
than this one.
And you definitely want to take
your time with this one.
But it's also important to
take your time with even
larger scale ones.
And those will be Behaviorism,
Taylorism, and the history and
the purpose of those schools.
And we'll talk about those
after the break.
It's 9:58 right now.
So we'll start at 10:08
according to that clock.
The first barrier, cognitive
dissonancy is a--
to a personal psychology.
But now we're going to look
at factors that span the
individual.
I mean, this spans the
individual in the sense that
it's the common feature of our
psychology, maybe of this
[INAUDIBLE] psychology.
But let's see it in
individual people.
But they're are also features
that are common across--
you could call them social
psychology or social
tendencies.
The first one is Behaviorism.
Behaviorism is also a school
of psychology, which,
basically in America, grew
out of Pavlov's work on
conditioning dogs and working on
teaching patience by reward
and punishment.
And in psychology, what it was
is it was a focus on outputs.
So it basically denied the
importance of studying what's
going on inside the
human mind.
It was correlated with what
was called the logical
positivism in the
Vienna school.
So in Europe, around the same
time and soon after, was the
rise of quantum mechanics.
So if you look at quantum
mechanics, quantum mechanics
was created partly by the Vienna
logical positivists in
math in [INAUDIBLE].
In quantum mechanics what's one
of the fundamental ideas
is what's called an observer.
You know, where it says, look.
Don't talk about what's
not observable.
The important thing is
what's observable.
Everything is sort of rigid
around observance.
All right, so behaviorist
psychology was
almost in the same way.
It says, look, don't talk
about the mind.
We don't know what
the mind is.
It has no separate existence.
Let's just talk about
behaviors.
How does what you do effect
what the organism does?
It's a fine way of training
pigeons, but it's not a great
way of understanding people.
But you can see that it's
actually dominant in lots of
American education.
So Behaviorism was actually
strongest in America, It was
eventually, I would say,
demolished as an intellectual
movement basically
in this space.
I guess the old linguistic
department was here.
And Noam Chomsky in 1957, '59
wrote the review of Skinner's
book on Behaviorism.
And that's considered the coup
de grace of Behaviorism.
But even then, the
idea lives on.
And it underlies so much of what
goes on in this school.
And you can see that with
actually the lively examples
of that, given the core.
I'll give you one more
of that [INAUDIBLE].
So this was a study.
This was fourth, fifth,
and sixth grade.
And they were asked what's
six times three.
Well, they weren't having a
problem with that, It's 18.
They were asked to make
a story problem for 6
times 3 equals 18.
80% of the students
could not do it.
They couldn't make a valid
story problem.
Now, what I mean by story
problem is a word problem.
So they could actually do
the multiplication.
That was no problem.
But to make a problem which used
that multiplication, that
was difficult for them.
Most of the problems they came
up with were along this line.
On Monday, Johnny
buys six apples.
It's always Johnny, not John.
I don't know why.
On Tuesday, Johnny buys
three apples.
So 6 times 3 equals 18.
There's was a fundamental lack
of understanding of what's
going on here behind
the equation.
So the performance was fine.
He said, what's 6 times 3?
18.
And so the observable
was [INAUDIBLE].
So by the [INAUDIBLE] standards
that was fine.
There was no problem.
And so much of it was
on the school.
Bacon just looks at
the outreach.
Whereas, if you actually look
into the [INAUDIBLE], that
Behaviorists say you shouldn't
really do, and ask the tougher
[? question, you'll ?] find
it actually has no meat.
But it's just like tissue.
AUDIENCE: Is the problem here
me, or is it we are looking
for the wrong outputs?
I don't see, per se, how asking
students to make a word
problem is looking into the mind
any deeper than asking
them 6 times 3 equals 18 because
it's an output that's
closer to what we
want students to
actually be able to do.
PROFESSOR: The thing is if they
this, if they produce a
correct story as a formula
too, then you wouldn't be
happy either.
So in some way you want
to know does this
have meaning for them.
So you could then say, well,
6 times 3 is 18.
OK, they understood that.
Now, I want them to
give me the right
output of a story problem.
Well, I have them memorize
a correct story problem.
Whenever they see
multiplication, do this kind
of story problem.
And then, if you ask them the
question give me a story
problem, they would produce
the right output.
But you'd still be unhappy.
You'd have to ask a different
question to figure out if it
actually had any meat.
Maybe for example you'd say,
well, multiplication's pretty
similar to division, so let me
see if they could make a story
problem for division.
Or let me give them a
different question,
which is this one.
Suppose they hadn't had this
question before and hadn't
been pigeon trained with it.
So you could give them that
question and see if they
understood what really
multiplication means.
If they just write down 73,
you would say, OK, they
understood that.
And it would be kind of
pointless to try and have them
memorize all questions
like this.
But after they've seen this kind
of question, yeah, they
might produce the
right output.
If you just tell them, OK,
whenever you see this, one,
two, three, four guys here and
four there, produce 73 here.
Well, that's different from
really in understanding
multiplication.
So I would say output
is not sufficient.
So you have to look
behind the output.
Did that help answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Well, but I feel
like you're still looking
[INAUDIBLE] but the difference
is the process you used to get
the students to the point where
they can generate that.
PROFESSOR: No.
Well, you're looking at the
output, because that's all you
can look at.
But you're not saying if the
output is fine, it's--
you're making inferences about
what's going behind that.
And that's what behaviorists
don't want.
You're saying, oh, there's
understanding, there's
meaning, there's reasoning going
on beyond the output.
And that's what the Behaviorists
don't want to
talk about.
They just want to talk about
just the outputs.
And that's a fundamental
problem.
Because real understanding--
focus on just outputs leads
to rote learning.
And I think that is one
explanation for why there's so
much rote learning produced in
the American education system.
AUDIENCE: Does anyone--
[INAUDIBLE]
[? location ?]
making the contributions
[INAUDIBLE] like understanding
a problem, [INAUDIBLE].
So what's the operation for
that that's different from
making up problem.
Making up a problem requires
more understanding, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Making up a problem does
require a lot of
understanding.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So society wise, you only need
a person to solve the problem
not make up a problem, right?
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
not the purpose of--
so do mean prompt people
to just solve
problems or make up problems?
That can't be the premise
on [INAUDIBLE]
democratic society.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK.
I agree with that.
But why should [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Who's happy to
choose the computation?
They know that 6
times 3 is 18.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well,
so it depends.
So on the [INAUDIBLE] in many
schools there's tests that
just test things like that.
[INAUDIBLE] .
So the No Child Left Behind Act
has pretty much mandated
that children be tested
pretty regularly
on their basic skills.
And so there's a ton of
questions and things like that
on these basic skills tests.
So some people care.
And these kind of tests are an
impediment to making any kind
of educational change.
Because if you start spending
time on things like that,
well, then you have less time
to practice three-digit by
five-digit multiplication.
AUDIENCE: Now this
[INAUDIBLE].
We should say [INAUDIBLE]
point first, and then from there
break it down to the
[INAUDIBLE]
much more [INAUDIBLE]
than [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That may be true.
So the comment was that maybe
it's better to try something
not so hard as making
up a story problem.
Identify--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
[INAUDIBLE] that we need.
PROFESSOR: It shouldn't
be that hard.
AUDIENCE: I mean, we're
on a skill, right?
PROFESSOR: It shouldn't be that
hard, but it is hard if
you've just done drill.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If you start so low--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I agree.
So it's not saying that
all of a sudden now--
I'm not saying all of a sudden
now you should ask what we're
doing with this question how
to make a story problem.
But this is used as an example
to show how far away we are
from where we'd like to be.
So Behaviorism is, I would say
branded reward and punishment,
pretty much rampant in
American society.
In discussions of merit pay for
teachers, OK, should we
give teachers higher pay if
their students do better on
tests from No Child
Left Behind?
So that is the assumption that
you want more output from the
teacher in that [INAUDIBLE].
You just pay more money.
You give them more
pigeon food.
But there actually maybe other
reasons going on, there may be
completely other factors
besides input output.
For example, maybe teachers
think we shouldn't be teaching
the test this way.
Maybe there's all kinds of
social consideration which
aren't included in just paying
people quote "meritly." So you
could see how rampant it is
because when you say, oh no,
we shouldn't do that
to teachers, people
think you're crazy.
They say, well, of course we
should-- and then they make a
really, really long argument
for why we shouldn't.
So the default is, yeah,
everything should be paid
according to results and
rewards, and rewarding
according to result.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about what
you think-- because I do
think that there is no question
that in our society
things in which we give respect
to and value as a
society do get paid more and
[INAUDIBLE] to have more
perspective as we [INAUDIBLE]
our educational system is that
we don't pay our teachers
anything and
don't respect them.
And that's why very few people
actually consider that as a
real career.
[INAUDIBLE]
you know, [INAUDIBLE]
to actually consider
teaching at my school.
Very [INAUDIBLE] rate.
And that's because it's
not respected.
It's not considered a
challenging [INAUDIBLE].
But don't you think that the
amount of money that people
get paid actually does in some
sense request our respect for
them as a society?
PROFESSOR: That I agree with.
So there's the meaning
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, there's meaning associated
with the salary.
So the problem, what's wrong
with merit pay is that the
meaning is that you're competing
with other teachers.
I'll give some money to the
schools and say, now dole it
out among your teachers.
And the one's who do best---
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
No, I think that's
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But I agree with
you about increasing the
overall salaries for teachers.
And it's exactly right what
you say that it's not
respected as a profession
in this country.
And as you say, people who get a
Ph.D from MIT are not likely
to teach in high school,
which is, I think, sad.
But it doesn't have
to be that way.
So in Europe--
so George Collier, one of the
greatest mathematicians of the
century, he taught at
a Swiss high school.
It was a considered a very
respectable position and
profession.
It's a serious profession.
It's really important.
Whereas, that's pretty
much unheard of here.
And [INAUDIBLE].
So it's a combination of
respect and salary.
And related to that, autonomy.
So teachers here in America
generally have the least
autonomy compared to, say,
Western European countries.
So one way of measuring that
is just how much free time
teachers have to do curriculum
[INAUDIBLE].
So think back to your
own high school.
How many classes did
your teacher teach?
Typically, six a day.
I mean, I'm exhausted if I
teach two classes today.
Because it really takes energy
to teach a class really well,
think about it, prepare, answer
questions, follow up
with what happened, and
make references.
Teaching six times
a day is absurd.
And all you can do is
just try to survive.
So that's, again, another
barrier to educational change.
So that is barrier number
two which is--
the second we'll call
the [INAUDIBLE].
So it's the focus on outputs
and reward and punishment.
And then the next barrier is
another social wide factor
called Taylorism.
So Taylor--
it's related a bit
to Behaviorism.
So Frederick Taylor was
a mechanical engineer.
Let's see, when did he live?
About 1850ish to about
1915 or 1920.
1856 to 1915.
So what he did--
he's the originator of time
and motion studies.
So time and motion studies
watch how someone, for
example, is riveting
bolts onto a car.
And you watch every single
movement and you optimize it.
And you say, oh, actually if
you have the screwdriver on
this side, well then when the
car door comes down this way
you can do this with much
shorter movement than trying
to do that.
So they said you can break every
task down with a lots of
little little fragments
you can optimize.
Now, this basically took the
whole country by storm in the
1910s or so.
Now, how did that happen?
Well, this was a time of
industrial unrest.
And unions were striking
demanded higher wages.
And there was the Interstate
Commerce Commission, which
regulated the railroad fares.
And so the railroad attorney,
Louis Brandeis, later Supreme
Court Justice, argued the in
front of the Interstate
Commerce Commission, well,
actually we don't have to
raise fares.
And we can actually give the
unions some of what they want
without doing any of
that provided we
implement Taylor's system.
So the idea of Taylor's system
was a way of basically trying
to prevent the unions from
striking, but not distribute
any of the wealth for
management, but just make
things more efficient.
So it was what we now call
the Cult of Efficiency.
And this Cult of Efficiency I
would say probably could only
happen in a frontier society,
like America.
So there's a completely
fascinating book, which I
highly recommend reading, The
Great Frontier, by Walter
Prescott Webb.
So what he looks at is he
looks at the effect on
European society of the European
discovery of the
Americas, so around 1500 BC.
Columbus sailed and all the
explorers were going a sail.
So what happened?
Well, before 1500 Europe was
extremely crowded, lots of
people, very few resources, very
little land, pretty much
deforested, not much fuel.
And so it was a hard
place to live.
With the discovery of the new
world, that switched.
There was now a ton of land
and not enough people,
especially after the Indians
all got small pox and died.
There was a ton of natural
resources-- wood, minerals,
eventually oil.
So around 1500, so the world
society changed.
At least the European society.
And with it, changed conceptions
of how society
should work.
And in the frontier societies,
basically everything was there
for the taking.
You just had to work
to get it.
So in a frontier society,
basically work was a religion.
That was the religion of
a frontier society.
And you can still see
that in America.
How many weeks of holidays
do people have completely
guaranteed?
I think zero.
And whereas in-- for example,
England, I think it was four
weeks, maybe statutory
minimum.
In Germany, it's five
or six weeks.
So in the frontier society, work
will be your religion.
And it's likely to be placed
where ideas such as Taylorism
will grow, and sprout,
and thrive.
So Taylorism spread throughout
the entire country, including
to the schools.
And you can still see
it in school.
School is considered
a factory.
And the inputs are
the students.
And we want to do that as
efficiently as possible.
Think class size, giant
buildings to [INAUDIBLE]
to produce more product
at the end.
So this is one of the early
examples of a Taylor school.
The Platoon School.
So this was an elementary
school.
What they did was they--
this is absurd.
They enrolled 10% to 70% more
children than there were seats
for in the classrooms.
So [INAUDIBLE]
efficiency.
This is done by dumping the 10%
to 70% on the playground,
into the auditorium
or basement.
So by keeping all the children
rotating from room to room,
teacher to teacher, so that
the same 10% to 70%
[INAUDIBLE] way longer than 30
consecutive minutes to get
into classrooms.
So even the 6-year-old children
have 6 or 7 teachers
a day and as many as 12
or 13 in some cities.
And teachers handle as many as
400 people through the day and
1,000 a week.
So the terrorists came to the
school and said, hey, look,
these schools-- it's all very
relevant to have small schools
for people, but really,
it's not efficient.
Look, there's all this
inefficiency you could squeeze
out of the system.
And so you can see probably
MIT's going to be going
through something like that with
the budget cuts, all the
[INAUDIBLE].
And trying to squeeze
the life--
I mean, the inefficiencies
out of the place.
So what they said was they said,
oh, look, there are all
these rooms that aren't
being used.
You have the gym that's
not used all the time.
There's the lunch room that's
only used at lunch time.
That's crazy.
There's an empty room there.
There's the playground that's
only used at recess.
What we should do is we
should rotate the
kids all the way through.
And you'll actually see
that in schools now.
Many of them have lunch period
that starts at 10:00 AM, and
the lunch period goes till
almost 2:00, because it's a
much more efficient use
of the lunch room.
But ironically, they had to
cancel recess, because recess
is inefficient.
Recess is not efficient for
doing standardized test
problems, so you guys will
see that as well.
So again, they called
it efficiency.
That was back in the
'20s [INAUDIBLE].
It's from Raymond Callahan's
book called Education and the
Cult of Efficiency: A Study of
the Social Forces that have
Shaped the Administration
of Public School.
It's about Taylorism in
the public schools.
But it continues to today.
In No Child Left Behind,
you can see is a
perfect example of it.
[INAUDIBLE]
wrote, he said, "The long lines
of marching children
that look to be like nothing
so much as the lines of
uncompleted Ford cars in the
factory, moving always on with
a screw put on or a [INAUDIBLE]
tighten as they
passed-- standardized,
mechanical, pitiful.
When the factory system carried
into the public
school, which needs only the
closing time whistle to make
complete [INAUDIBLE] with
giant, great industrial
plants."
So there you have another
fundamentally
important social factor.
[INAUDIBLE].
So behaviorism and Taylorism are
sort of lumped together.
Which is the joining of the
school and the factory and the
educational system and
the social order.
So that I'll call the social
history of education.
So education-- and America was
one of the leading countries
in this, in making schools
free and required--
compulsory free education.
[INAUDIBLE] public school.
So this-- in Massachusetts,
actually-- our state was the
leading state in American
[INAUDIBLE].
And so Horace Mann
in the 1840s--
he was one of the leading
educational reformers.
And he was arguing
to businessmen.
OK, you really should be willing
to have higher taxes
to make schools free
and required.
Now, why would businesses want
to part with their profits to
pay for schools?
But he says, look, there's all
these benefits from schools.
The schooled workers are more
docile and quick in applying
themselves to work.
They had better domestic and
social habits, you know,
punctuality and fidelity.
They have higher punctuality
and fidelity in the
performance of their duties.
So basically, he was arguing
for school as a method of
social control.
Now, there was a strange feature
in my high school,
which I never understood till
I actually read about this.
History of Horace Mann called
the School of America, which
was that-- so I experienced
this first-hand.
One day in my high school, this
racist student attacked
me and called me nasty names.
And so when I fought back--
and we sort of fought to a draw,
which was good because
he was trying to do
serious damage.
As a result, the school policy
was that whoever was in the
fight was suspended
for three days.
So we were both automatically
suspended, and then had to go
to court to figure out who
was really at fault.
But by then, of course,
I'd already been
suspended for two days.
So I was suspended for three
days and I got to find out,
what are the policies when
you miss school?
So it was very interesting.
So first of all, if you're late
to school three times in
a quarter, then you fail
for that quarter.
If you fail in the second
quarter of a semester, you
fail the semester.
If you fail in the second
semester of a course, you fail
the entire year.
And if you failed a required
course, like English--
math or English required-- then
you failed the entire
year and had to repeat
the whole grade.
OK, so they were very, very,
very sticklers about
punctuality.
But they didn't really
care what your
grades were that much.
You could get C's and D's on
tests and you'd do much better
than if you missed four
days of school.
Now, my teachers were
nice in this case.
Said, no, don't worry
about it.
Good thing you fought and
stood up for yourself.
We won't do any of that stuff.
So it was always puzzling to me
why punctuality was so much
more important in this public
school, which was supposed to
be one of the leading public
schools [INAUDIBLE], than the
actual grades you got and
how much you learned.
When I read the history
of Horace Mann, I
thought, oh, yeah.
That actually made
perfect sense.
The purpose of the school wasn't
necessarily to teach
people to think and
really understand.
The social history behind it was
to produce people who are
basically docile workers for the
factory system, which was
just coming around
in the 1840s.
So there were many comments
along those lines.
One of the arguments also for
the school was similar.
It was a resolution that the
best police for our cities,
the lowest insurance of our
houses, the permanent security
for our banks, the most
effective means of preventing
pauperism, vice, and crime, and
the only sure defense of
our country are our
common schools.
They mean the public, free
schools that are required.
So again, it's seen
as a defense
of property, basically.
This was true-- so when I say
America, it's not just
America, actually.
England in 1870 passed an
education act that required
public schooling.
[INAUDIBLE].
And the arguments in England
were almost exactly the same.
"Would not the policemen be
better employed in assisting
the work of the school master by
collecting [INAUDIBLE] for
school attendance the willfully
neglected children
who are [INAUDIBLE] recruits for
the great army of crime."
We wanted to prevent the working
classes from engaging
in those vain strikes which end
in 99 out of 100 leaving
them in worse condition
than before.
We wanted to keep them from
habits of waste and
improvidence that some knowledge
of the succession of
events in life, such as
education could supply.
So in other words, education
has a class role.
So that history of education,
it still permeates it.
And people were very
open about this.
These weren't secret documents
that people wrote in their
conspiratory council.
These were openly discussed,
saying this is why you should
pay for schools.
I would say it was even quite
a soph-- reached quite a
sophisticated level.
So William Whewell, he was
master of Trinity College,
Cambridge, in the
1860s, I think.
So when he was a university
professor, before becoming
master at Trinity, he was
commenting on the difference
between the European and the,
say, English and American
educational system.
And he said, well, actually,
they had [INAUDIBLE]
problem in Europe.
And the problem [INAUDIBLE].
So he was recommending the
teaching of mathematics.
He said, "The mathematical
doctrines
were fixed and permanent.
No new system of geometry
can supersede the old.
Not only so, but even the old
books remain in use."
So now contrasting that, "The
fixed and constant nature of
mathematics was not likely to
promote the critical spirit
[INAUDIBLE]
France and Germany, where too
much attention to the more
provisional and contentious
observational sciences had
been partly responsible for the
imminent general hostility
to the existing institutions
in their country."
So in other words, we should
teach mathematics because it
has one answer.
[INAUDIBLE]
conclude about society, too.
It has the one answer, which
is the society we have.
Whereas, if you teach
observational sciences, social
sciences, people might start
questioning way too much.
So there was not just schools,
but what should we teach in
our schools?
So that history is very, very
hard to overcome because it's
so deeply embedded into the
foundation of a school.
We will find its purpose
is like that.
Such purposes keep creeping
up whenever you
try to change things.
So there are all kinds of things
that are crazy in the
schools that we do that you
don't necessarily need to do
in the school.
For example, grading.
Why do schools have to grade?
People think, oh, well, how
will other people know?
If other people want to know
what students can do, let them
worry about it.
Why does the school
have to do that?
Sure, it's school.
It could tell students, look
you're not learning this idea
very well, you could spend
more time on that.
You're learning this
idea really good.
You don't need to spend
any more time on that.
That kind of evaluation, for
the student's benefit, is
quite useful.
But why should that be
publicized to other people?
Well, those are two separate
questions, but they're
automatically conflated
because-- partly, the purpose
of the school is to get
people to accept their
place in the society.
There was a very interesting
experiment along those lines.
I don't know if you know it.
It was blues eyes, brown eyes.
So this is related to tracking
and grading.
So I don't think you could
do this experiment today.
But what they was they took--
I think it was third graders.
And they came into the
class and they said,
OK, you third graders.
We've just found out that the
blue-eyed children are more
intelligent than brown-eyed
children.
And so we're going to have
to teach them separately.
So they then separated into two
classrooms and they taught
them exactly the same stuff.
And then they tested them a
while later and they found the
blue-eyed children did much,
much better than the
brown-eyed children.
So sure, the test results
must have been correct.
Actually what they did is
afterwards they said,
actually, no we fucked up--
sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
We screwed up.
And actually, we got
it backwards.
It was the brown-eyed children
who were more intelligent than
the blue-eyed children.
So we had to switch
the classrooms.
So they switched
And of course, they taught them
exactly the same stuff.
And what do you think happened
[INAUDIBLE]?
They flipped.
That's an example
of the effect of
tracking and grading.
So what's the result of that is
that, well, students then
accept their place.
They think, oh, yeah.
I am the dumb student.
I am the bad reader.
Oh, I'm just not so
good at math.
It's my fault.
Rather than-- well, it's
the way it's taught.
It's that I came from a family
where we just didn't have much
money, even for food.
And the society just didn't
provide that, so I was
hungry every day.
So there's all kinds of social
explanations which you're
taught not to look at.
And even the very problems that
are done in school tend
to reinforce the social
order that we have.
So an example of that, to really
show how strong that
tendency is, is look at the
problems that are done about
percentages.
The percentage problems are
always of the following form.
Johnny has $1,000 which he lends
to Jane at 6% interest.
How much interest does Jane
pay after two years?
Well, there's many interesting
features about that.
First of all, Johnny
makes the money.
The guy has the money
and not the woman.
The woman is the borrower.
So now, with feminism, we've
made it so that Jane
can have the money.
But you haven't changed the
fundamental problem, which is
that the problem is
reinforcing the
idea of money lending.
[INAUDIBLE].
What about the following
problem, which you never see,
which is also [INAUDIBLE]
interesting percentage problem?
The hourly minimum wage
is $7 an hour.
If somebody works 40 hours a
week, what's their salary?
OK, it's this much.
It's roughly $14,000 a year.
What percentage of the
federal poverty line
is $14,000 a year?
That's an equally interesting
percentage problem, but it has
a different social message.
So the schools have chosen,
basically [INAUDIBLE] social
pressures that push towards one
kind of problem, one kind
of grading, one kind
of system.
And this is despite what people
know about these things.
So blue eyes, brown eyes
experiment shows what's the
detrimental effect
[INAUDIBLE].
Many people say, well, actually,
Another example is tracking.
So tracking where people
know that it's harmful.
So a friend of mine in New
York, he went to an elite
private school.
It's a small, elite
And one year they decided
to introduce tracking.
So tracking is advanced math,
median math, OK math, and
remedial math.
And after a year, there was
a parental revolt and they
abolished it.
The parents said, this
is outrageous.
We're not paying $25,000 a year
for you to tell our kid
that our kid is not
intelligent.
Get rid of it.
Whereas, it's considered
perfectly acceptable to do
that to kids in public
schools.
So people know, yet
the thing goes on.
So whenever you see something
like that happening, you can
bet there's some really deeply
embedded social history--
the purposes of the schools.
And related to the social
history is the social history
of our society.
So these tendencies, they're
not immutable.
All social factors have changed
in the past and all of
them can change again.
But in order to change them,
It's important to be aware.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I just had a question with the
whole concepts of getting the
grades, which I can see is
a benefit in some ways.
But I feel like [INAUDIBLE]
to just stop grading children,
I feel like at least at the
level of college acceptance,
there's still going to be some
level of evaluating
the children.
And eventually, it's just going
to be that some other
form of evaluation is leading
to this separation, even if
it's not just by numbers.
Saying [INAUDIBLE].
And is there any way you could
really deal with it without
having grades?
PROFESSOR: Well, I think
you've identified the
fundamental problem, which
is the competition.
So it's sort of like
the water bed.
If you sit on one side
of the water bed, the
other side goes up.
So if you reduce the competition
in one place, it
might increase in other ways.
So for example, you have no
grades in high schools, but
then you have a really, really
high stakes university
entrance exam, which is not
necessarily the ideal solution.
I think the ideal solution
is that you make good
universities accessible
to all people.
Or, for example, if you make
it so that you don't need a
university degree to earn
a decent salary.
AUDIENCE: But is that ever
going to be possible?
PROFESSOR: Well, I always quote
Margaret Mead on that,
"Never underestimate the power
of a small number of people
[INAUDIBLE]
to make social change." And not
just a small number, but
people in general.
So all things that we now think
are absurd and just
horrible were once normal.
Slavery was considered
absolutely normal.
And in fact, the view of the
inferior races [INAUDIBLE].
But all these things that we
think are horrible now--
torture--
are now considered just beyond
the pale because of social
[INAUDIBLE].
So my main point here is that
these are structural,
fundamental, large issues.
And they require structural and
large society-wide changes
to fundamentally change them.
But it goes both ways.
The schools themselves produce
people who reinforce the
social structures.
So if people had come through
the blue eyes, brown eyes
experiment and they feel
themselves that they are not
worthy, they're less likely to
try and make a social change
to make a just society.
So it goes both ways.
Improving the schools and the
educational system improves
the society.
Improving the society improves
the schools.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you could take advantage of
that blue-eyed, brown-eyed
thing, like to say--
one could say something like,
oh, people in that class
always did really well in their
future physics classes.
And then everyone could just
be like, oh, great.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's a great point.
So the point was, could you
take advantage of the blue
eyes, brown eyes experiment
to just tell people, look,
everyone in my physics
class does great.
And so just, actually,
make people do well?
There is actually a fair amount
of data that does work.
So [INAUDIBLE] wasn't phrased
in exactly that way, but the
example I'm thinking of
is women's colleges.
So a large portion of women in
science Ph.D's come from
all-women's colleges.
And I think that's partly
that effect.
In the regular society, women
are generally told, look,
[INAUDIBLE] the Barbie doll
that was taken off,
[INAUDIBLE]
Barbie doll that for a
while said, oh, math.
Math is hard.
I don't do math, or something
like that.
That's what it taught.
It's really amazing that they
thought they could do that.
So there was huge outcry and
they had to take it-- some
people did spoofs.
They put that as a Ken doll and
they put a big, deep voice
in the Barbie doll just
to play on that.
But that social attitude does
permeate the society.
And it's much less in the
all-women's colleges.
So places like Swarthmore, Bryn
Mawr, and Smith where
women are-- it's
just expected.
Of course you're going to
do well in science.
Everyone around here does
well in science.
It's not considered
anything special.
It's considered a good thing,
but it's not [INAUDIBLE]
to women.
So they already took away the
blue eyes or the brown eyes
and just put everyone
[INAUDIBLE].
So I think that is a reason
for not criticizing kids.
When you're raising young
children or teaching them
things, don't criticize them.
And same with grades
at a university.
Grades should be so the students
can figure out what
they need to learn more of,
but not as a way of making
them feel bad.
That's so hard to do when people
have been graded or
degraded for so long.
Question, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted to go
back to your earlier point
about competition, how it takes
it away from one place
and it ends up another place.
PROFESSOR: I don't say
it's conserved.
But you have to think about
the whole system.
Yeah, so I agree with
the question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Not only it doesn't scale
because of limited resources.
You can't keep everybody
in teacher one on one.
It would be great if it
took, but the system
won't work that way.
We won't have enough teachers.
So there's always going to be
competition for resources.
I just want to--
PROFESSOR: Well, OK, so the
question of competition.
So let me close with one quote,
and then I'll come to
your question.
OK, so it's a good question.
So to continue the rest
of what Einstein said.
So remember, before Einstein
said that one had to cram all
this stuff into one's mind,
whether one liked it or not.
"This [INAUDIBLE]
effect that after I passed the
final exam, I found the
consideration of any
scientific problems
distasteful to me for
the entire year.
It is, in fact, nothing short
of a miracle that the modern
methods of instruction have
not entirely strangled the
[? whole new ?]
curiosity required.
For this delicate little plant,
aside from stimulation,
stands mainly in need
of freedom.
Without this, it goes to wrack
and ruin without fail."
So I hope that when you're out
in the world, when you're
teaching and raising your
children, that you find ways
to make more freedom
in education.
So that when the students
actually that you produce
improve the society, and they
then, can help you improve the
schools and the rest of
the education system.
OK, your question about
competition.
It is a fundamental one.
And about competition for
resources, you have to really--
so make a radical analysis.
So radical in Latin
means to the root.
So you have to get to the
root of the problem.
So the root of the problem, you
can see it in the extreme
case of India where there are
so many people and so few
comfortable jobs, and the route
to the comfortable job
is in education.
That's there's intense
competition for
tutors and all this.
Not because people want to
learn, but because that's the
means to actually not starve
on the street.
So what that shows is that not
everyone wants to learn with a
tutor differential equations.
But a lot of people are
learning differential
equations with a tutor because
that means they'll get a
degree, which means they can
work in investment bank, which
means-- well, it used to
mean that they would be
comfortable.
So part of the issue is of
redistributing the wealth in
the society, so that you're
comfortable whether or not you
had a tutorial in differential
equations
or one-on-one tutorial.
Then, when the fears are taken
away, people are much more
likely to do things for
intrinsic reasons.
So the people who really
are interested in
that, then do that.
The people who are really
interested in teaching that
will teach that.
And you'll have a redirection
of social resources in much
more productive way.
But that requires, for example,
the value of, say,
guaranteed income, guaranteed
health care.
Maybe even guaranteed basic
schooling for everyone, so
that those things are features
of competition.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But the system based
on competition is quite
self-regulating, right?
PROFESSOR: I don't
know about that.
So a good example-- is the
system based on competition
self-regulating?
I'm not sure about that.
I mean, the mortgage derivative
market is a great
example that-- actually, what
happened was-- you can think
of it in electrical
engineering terms.
You had--
let's do it under
continuous time.
So you had some sort of slow,
pokey banking system with
feedback loops and the poles
were [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE], nice
decay constant.
And then, the competition to
make more money quickly--
well, one way to make more
money was to trade
[INAUDIBLE].
What did that do?
It increased the gaming of
feedback loops and [INAUDIBLE]
the poles this way.
And eventually, some of the
poles crossed the axis and you
got huge nonlinear oscillations,
which grew to--
huge oscillations grew to
nonlinear [INAUDIBLE] and
broke a whole bunch of the
world banking system.
So it's actually not necessarily
true that
competition is self-regulating,
because there
are all these nonlinearities
and feedbacks and delays in
the system, there's no
guarantee of that.
And one of the harms of the
competition is it puts people
against each other.
And what'd you much rather
have is people working
together and helping
each other.
Because as studies quoted by
[INAUDIBLE] showed, that
actually-- if you want it to go
a high level, [INAUDIBLE].
That's how it happens.
Not through competition and
dog-eat-dog, but people
cooperating and sharing
knowledge.
And what we wanted to do, I
would say in our educational
system, is shift it more towards
there and free people
[INAUDIBLE] for creating
the [INAUDIBLE].
Instead of [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So we don't determine
the pay of different
people in the society
based on the
competition, what do you propose?
Do you propose that somebody
else decides [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, we already
have all kinds of ways.
I mean, you can have
regulations.
You could, for example.
Say, I mean, income tax is a
social way of deciding what's
worthwhile and what's not.
You could say, OK, we're going
to tax peoples' income the
99%, beyond 200,000.
[INAUDIBLE].
And we're going to use that
money to pay teachers more.
That's a social choice because
saying the teachers'
salaries are this.
If you think it's a worthwhile
thing to do we could say look,
we think bridge building
is really important it
revitalizes the [INAUDIBLE].
We're going to pay people
to do that.
Those are social choices,
just like anything.
It doesn't have to
be permissive.
All right?
So we can change our educational
system that way.
The barrier to it is that our
thoughts are limited by the
educational system that
we went through.
So in one way that's bad news,
because there was this giant
feedback loop keeping things
the way they are.
On the other hand, because
there's a feedback loop, the
educational system affects the
society and vice versa.
Well, it means you can work
anywhere on the feedback loop
you want that you think
is interesting.
You could try to improve
the society directly.
You could try to improve the
educational system in
[INAUDIBLE].
You can try to skip the feedback
wherever you see it.
Insert something good in here.
And you improve things for
everybody that way.
OK, so if you could fill
out the question sheet.
[INAUDIBLE]
put on the website
who [INAUDIBLE]
as well as referenced
[INAUDIBLE].
And next time we'll have a
summary of all of the second
[INAUDIBLE]
as well as questions from you.
Because I know I have a few
questions that I have to
answer plus [INAUDIBLE].
So we'll try to answer all your
questions [INAUDIBLE].
Answers from lecture
10 to questions
generated in lecture 9.
PROFESSOR: OK, lots of questions
from last time.
So I won't answer all of them
because otherwise we'll
probably spend the entire
time just on the
questions from last time.
Which maybe I should have
anticipated since it's a
central topic and one that
connects to not just
education, but directly to
society, the topic on
political barriers to
educational change.
So I'll answer some of those.
But then I wanted to also give
you a chance to ask any
questions that have been
unresolved that have come up
in your teaching or that
you think might
come up in your teaching.
One of my old teachers, Don
[? Knuth, ?] always reserved
the last session for
student questions.
And I think it's a really good
philosophy to tie everything
together, tie all the
loose ends up.
So I call it your turn.
OK, but part of your turn was
answering some of your
questions from before.
Is social education
a bad thing?
And so the comment was, I'm
still not convinced social
education is a bad thing.
Obviously it gives a lot of
control to whoever gets to
make the decision of what
constitutes a good citizen.
But some of the social agendas
in public schooling were good.
For example, diversity,
recycling.
And that's true.
So I don't want to be
misinterpreted as saying
society is a bad thing.
I think society naturally
educates people.
You pick up your values from
people around you.
Your parents give you
ethical norms.
Schools give you
And I think it's exactly what
the question said, it said who
gets to decide?
Is it some group of elites who
decide or is it the whole
society collectively deciding
what is good for everybody.
And what's good for everybody
may not be one thing.
It may be the decision is well,
different people need or
want different things.
And we think a good society is
based on the idea that people
have freedom to follow
their interests.
And also, some required work
that everyone need to learn,
for example, reading.
But then what you read
may be up to you.
So yeah, I don't think all
social education is a bad
thing at all.
I think all education
is social.
There's no way to avoid that.
Inherently we're
social animals.
And it's the question of what's
in that education?
And it's the same
thing, political
barriers educational change.
It's not that politics is
inherently a bad thing.
The question is, what kind
of politics do we have?
And how can we make that
better and more humane?
So for example, I think
recycling is a good example of
making things more humane.
OK, if competition demotivates
some people does it motivate
other people?
Does eliminating competition
reduce maximum performance?
Other than the studies referred
to by Alfie Kohn, I'm
not sure if the answer
to that is known.
I mean, there's certainly
studies on how, for example,
competition leads to
a lot of waste.
The classic example in economics
is suppose you--
and this was actually
a real example--
give people 160 acres
of land--
I think that was the a 1/4
plot-- or 640 acres of land
way out in the west.
And the rule is whoever gets
there first gets to claim that
piece of land.
And you get there and you stick
posts up and you put a
fence there.
That's roughly how the
Homestead Act worked.
Well, the problem with
that is that it does
cause a lot of waste.
Which is that tons of people
might run out and
chase after that land.
And make a whole bunch of effort
buying train tickets,
go on a wagon with their
whole family out west.
But only one person
gets the land.
So a whole bunch of people
actually put in a lot of
wasted effort.
So that's a classic example
of how competition
can be quite wasteful.
Other examples, where exclusive
rights do that, or patents.
So as is the case, a patent's
only given to one person--
or the inventor--
and you have 15 people
or 30 people
trying to invent something.
So the more the competition, in
this case, the more waste
is going to happen.
Because all these people are
going to invest funds.
But only one person is going
to get the exclusive right.
And the other people are
just left high and dry.
So there's many examples where
eliminating competition will
actually increase the amount of
social wealth contributed
towards useful ends.
But to the direct question of
whether it reduces maximum
forms, I don't know
if that's known.
The studies in Alfie Kohn's
article pointed to how
competition reduces high-level
performance.
For example, complex
cognitive tasks.
Maximum performance, probably,
one would need to define that
pretty closely.
And then one could
do studies on it.
OK, so there was an interesting
question about the
understanding multiplication.
So the understanding
multiplication example I gave,
where people could multiply
6 by 3 and get 18 but then
couldn't come up with a word
problem that used 6 by 3.
Or they could, but the word
problem was Johnny buys 6
apples on Monday.
He buys 3 apples on Tuesday.
So 6 times 3 is 18.
So that was, maybe, a bit
unfair to ask students.
Because writing a story draws on
skills beyond mathematical
understanding such as
imagination and language.
So it's true, it does draw
on those skills.
But I don't think those are
separate from mathematical
understanding.
If you can't explain the
mathematics that you in you,
you don't really
understand it.
When I was an undergraduate a
friend of mine and I used to
torment the math
grad students.
It was sort of unfair.
And we were really curious
about math.
We were fascinated by math.
And we wanted to know what
people do in graduate school.
And only later did
I realize we were
actually tormenting them.
We weren't doing it
intentionally.
We would ask them, OK, what
are you working on?
Sometimes we had classes with
them or we'd see them in the
math lounge.
And they would say, oh, blah,
blah, the theorem.
And we were undergraduates
and young.
And we didn't really know
what the theorem was.
So we'd say, well, can you
give us an example?
And that produced just deer
in the headlights.
Example?
That was completely foreign and
not at all what they were
thinking about.
It was completely out
of their space.
And later I actually realized
that that was actually a very
fair question.
And if you wanted to test
whether people understood what
they were working on.
And I found that things I can
give examples on I understand.
The things I can't, I
don't understand.
Another example that
is Feynman.
He said, I have always found
that I don't understand
anything unless I can give
a freshman lecture on it.
Or equivalently, people
asked him to give
a lecture on something.
He said, no, I don't
understand.
I don't understand
that well enough.
I'll have to first work out
a freshman lecture on it.
Then I can explain it better.
And so there's famous lectures
of his where he's explained
anti particles and spin.
And he finally got it to a level
where he thinks it was
actually suitable for a
freshman, so first-year
college students.
So it's a brilliant lecture.
If you search for the Dirac
Memorial Lectures by Feynman
you'll find that
lecture there.
And it's fascinating.
So it shows the level of how
hard work it is to actually
understand something
of that level.
And almost essential to that
process is examples.
So examples, explaining,
understanding, I think those
are intrinsic to mathematical
understanding.
So it wasn't an unfair test.
It was actually a test of
high-level mathematical
understanding.
One point was made, Swarthmore
was not a women's college.
Yeah, that's true.
I mentioned that women's
colleges were much more
successful in producing women
Ph.D. students in science.
And I listed Bryn
Mawr and Smith.
And then I listed Swarthmore,
which was not correct.
That was crosstalk between Bryn
Mawr is and Swarthmore.
I grouped them all, Bryn
Mawr, Haverford,
and Swarthmore together.
So Swarthmore is a coeducational
college.
And I meant Bryn
Mawr and Smith.
And I was thinking of
Wellesley as well.
So Wellesley is an all-women's
college, unless they've
changed lately?
No, OK.
I mean every once in a while
colleges think of changing.
But they're still all women.
Now, people asked for references
and further
information about that.
So I'll put a link
on the website.
But it's Barbara Whitten at the
Colorado College physics
department, she's done the most
extensive studies on not
just what makes for women being
successful in science,
but in general, what makes
for students in
say, physics majors.
She was the chair of the
Colorado College physics
department when I interviewed
there.
What makes for a successful
undergraduate major program?
So this is quite interesting
for people
interested in teaching.
Not just revising one course,
but revising an entire
department curriculum.
So she's done
cross-institutional studies of
the culture of departments and
what facets of the culture are
responsible for students
continuing on in science.
And what she's found is that
the same features that help
women continue in science
help everybody.
So I highly recommend
her work.
And I'll put a link to her web
page on our course web page.
Barbara Whitten.
I think it's W-I-T-T-E-N. But it
might be W-H-I-T-T-E-N, the
Colorado College physics
department.
OK, it's clear that I don't
like No Child Left Behind.
But would I do if I were
the Secretary of
Education in this country?
Yeah, well, Hell would probably
freeze over before
that happened.
There's a long vetting process
before people become that.
And you have to show your
loyalty to pretty much every
aspect of the current system
before that happens, before
you're appointed
to such a post.
But if Hell froze over
what would I do?
I think one of the fundamental
problems with education in
America is the vast
inequalities
in funding, in resources.
So the wealthy school districts
have two, three,
four times as much funds
per student as
the poor school districts.
And there's a good
part of that.
I mean, the disparity is bad.
But there's a reason
for the disparity.
And the reason isn't all bad.
The reason is that America
education is a local affair.
It's controlled by local
authorities.
So the constitution reserves
a bunch of powers for the
federal government, printing
money, making war, various
things like that.
Then it says, OK, then the
states can do a bunch of stuff
like, for example,
regulate voting.
And then it says anything not
explicitly given to the
national or state governments
is given to the people.
Or in fact I think it says--
this is the 10th or 11th
commandment--
especially devolution.
It says any powers not given to
the federal government go
to the state.
If they're given to the state.
And if not given to the state
they go to the people.
And so education is
in that category.
It's nowhere mentioned in the
constitution, education.
So it's not given
to the states.
It's not given to the
federal government.
So in America it's given to
the local authorities.
Now the problem is that
different communities have
different wealth bases.
Because there's some
very rich suburbs.
And for a while the cities
were wealthy.
But then people fled.
All the wealthy people fled the
cities in the 1950s during
suburbanization.
So the centers of cities
became very poor.
So there's vast disparities
in wealth there.
And I think one thing that the
federal government could do is
actually just correct those.
So there've been lawsuits along
those lines for forcing
state governments to try to
correct that because there is
some role for the states
in education.
I'm not sure where that comes
from in the constitution.
But there are state boards
of education.
And I think it's Vermont and
New Jersey, there've been
lawsuits in state courts to
force the states to equalize
funding across school
districts.
So somehow mitigating
the differential in
property-tax revenues.
And I think the federal
government
could do that as well.
So those lawsuits
are based on--
I'm pretty sure-- the 14th
Amendment, equal
protection of the laws.
Now, there's no reason the
federal government couldn't do
that as well.
So I would do that as
step number one.
No strings attached,
here, let's just
equalize the resources.
And then we can worry
about what we're
going to do after that.
Whereas No Child Left Behind,
what it does, it makes the
resources actually,
more unequal.
Because it tests all
the schools.
And the schools that are going
to do badly are the ones with
less resources.
And then they're going to get
punished for doing badly.
So I would take the
opposite approach.
Is there a particular country's
educational system
that I particularly admire?
That's a good question.
Again, I think it's local.
There's local educational
experiments that I admire a
lot and occasionally
larger-scale ones.
A whole country, not so much.
I mean, there's states
in India, for
example, for awhile Kerala--
I don't know if this is still
true-- but had an incredibly
high literacy rate, I think
98%, Which was much higher
than anywhere else in India
and matches literacy
levels in the West.
And this has many benefits.
So for example, one study
about population is that
population growth is slowed
down the most
by educating women.
And Kerala actually, that 98%
included women not just men.
So I think that's an educational
system worth
looking into.
And places that I admire,
there are local pockets.
The free schools in the 1960s.
There's a few places like
that still in America.
There's the Sudbury
Valley School.
Maybe it's 50 miles
west of here.
It's in the Sudbury Valley.
And that's modeled on
Summerhill, one of the
earliest free schools
in England.
So actually, it has
its good and bad.
So Summerhill, there's
no required classes.
And there's no required
curriculum.
And the students can
go to class or not
and can play outside.
So that would work
really well.
I think that works really
well if all the
teachers are really inspiring.
Because then the students would
be automatically drawn
in to learn stuff.
But if the teachers aren't very
skilled then you have
problems with that.
So I think it worked
mixed there.
But the potential is good and
the freedom is really good.
And it teaches people
to be responsible.
But it has its downsides.
So I have a personal experience
with that.
Which is when I was three.
So I was born in England.
And we lived there
for a few years.
And then we moved
to New Jersey.
And I guess I was four maybe,
my parents thought about
sending me to England
to go to Summerhill
because this was 1973.
So it was in the middle
of lots of
political change in America.
Free schools were a big part
of the cultural discussion.
And my parents believed
in those values, which
I'm glad they did.
And they thought, OK, let's see
about sending Sanjay to
Summerhill.
So we took a trip
back to England.
And they visited.
And the way they tell me what
happened, was that everything
was fine except then they were
wandering around with the
teacher on the tour.
And they saw these marks
on the door.
And they said, what are those
marks on the door?
Because they believed in the
philosophy of letting children
do what they want to do and
follow their interests.
But they said, oh, what are
those marks on the door there?
And they said, oh,
that's Johnny.
He likes to stand over there and
throw knives at the door.
So then my parents thought,
well, maybe that's just a
little too unsupervised.
Especially if the child is
across the Atlantic from us.
And it's not really easy to see
how things are going and
intervene if things aren't
going so well.
So they decided not to send
me to Summerhill.
But they sent me to progressive
nursery schools
locally as well.
And I have good memories
of those too.
So yeah, I would say there's a
fundamental point in there,
which is there's a difference
between freedom and license.
And so this is a distinction
not often made.
So license is the bad pole
and freedom is the good.
This is how I'm splitting
the two parts.
So license is just do
whatever you want.
Take drugs.
Be a prostitute.
Do whatever you want.
You're free.
Well, that's not
really freedom.
You're licensed.
Whereas freedom--
in my mind-- has some intrinsic
regulation on it.
You're free.
You're a free creature.
You have responsibility to
use that freedom well.
And license doesn't have any
of that responsibility.
So I think when one is designing
curricula like that
you have to try to make the
norm such that freedom is
promoted and not license.
Now, to some extent, you can't
avoid a bit of license.
Because, for example, the
Summerhill teachers say that
when students come from regular
schools where they've
been basically competing with
each other, basically feeling
beaten down, some of them come
to Summerhill and just do
nothing for a year.
They just sit outside and play
on the swings and in the
creek, just for a year.
It takes them a year of
detoxification before they are
ready to go back into
the classroom and
learn things formally.
So you could say that's
a bit of license.
But maybe that's a bit
of necessary license.
Or maybe they're actually just
discovering how to use freedom.
And it takes them a year because
they never had any
practice with that.
So I think it's important
to keep
those two pieces separate.
OK, so now there's so
many questions.
OK so there's two that I
think are particularly
important to discuss.
So there was a comment that one
of the Alfie Kohn readings
was off putting because he made
comments about people
with different political views
than his and he seemed like a
left-wing nut.
And that, therefore, that
reading shouldn't be assigned.
So yeah, I agree that if you
have quite a different
political view than Alfie Kohn
it can be a bit off putting.
But actually, I think
that's a good thing.
Now why is that?
It's because it's fundamentally
important to
find views that challenge you
and read them anyway.
So as you probably guessed,
most of my views are not
mainstream.
So I do that all the time
whether I like it or not, just
when I open the paper, or if I
happen to watch television,
which I actually don't
hardly at all.
But if I open the newspaper or
read things, just right next
to my office there was
a teaching magazine.
I forget what is called.
Prism maybe?
I forget the name
of the magazine.
But it's on the magazine
display.
And I just was walking by.
And turned my head this
way to read the title
on the front cover.
And it said cash incentives
are proving successful for
promoting student learning.
So this was against everything
I believed in.
So if I have the time I'll
actually read the article.
But I'm surrounded by things
I disagree with.
And I think that's actually
pretty healthy.
So if you disagree with
the article read
it all the way through.
And the law professor Cass
Sonstein from Chicago--
who's talked about as being
a possible Supreme
Court nominee by Obama--
he's written eloquently about
the dangers of not doing that.
Because it wasn't so possible
50 years ago.
There was large-circulation
newspapers and maybe two,
three in each town.
And people read those.
There was a common discourse
through that.
But now, everyone can get their
own particular news on
the internet.
Right?
You can get your own views from
this small journal or
from that particular newspaper
or this person writing an
article that you happen
to agree with.
And the danger is of people
just collecting into small
little micro communities, where
each community just
agrees with itself and only
reads things and discusses
things that they agree with.
And that's very unhealthy for
democracy he points out, which
I think is right.
So I think it's very important
to actually seek out things
you disagree with.
And so if I happen to give you
a reading that at first you
disagreed with it's not
such a bad thing.
And it belongs, for sure, in
an academic curriculum.
Because that's one of the
purposes of an academic
curriculum.
The word university comes from--
it has Uni in it, one.
So the idea is it's
one universe.
All ideas are open discussion,
even ones we disagree with.
OK, so let's see.
OK, then the related one is, I
find it off putting when I put
my personal biases and
opinions as absolute.
For example, programming--
and this is related to
the last point--
programming LaTeX may
be easier and more
convenient for me.
But it's possible to develop
familiarity with other
software and systems that
makes them close to
equivalent, if not equivalent.
That may be true.
Though I think there's
fundamental reasons to
wonder about it.
Just because By not using a
system such as LaTeX or Tex.
What's common about all of them
is that you program them.
And by not using a system like
that, you give up the ability
to program.
And that is a huge loss.
You can see it, how much
can computers do?
The way computers are
so powerful is
because we program them.
And the fundamental recipe
for programming is--
at least when I teach it--
this--
So this is how the fundamental
idea of programming I think.
So you do something and
then you do it again.
And when you're doing it
again, you're like,
oh, I just did this.
Maybe I should write
a program.
Nah, I'm too lazy.
But then the third time
it happens again.
And you're like, OK,
bloody hell, this
time write a program.
OK, so basically the recipe is
the third time you're about to
do something, don't do it.
Write a program to do it.
So now you have a little mini
program that you can reuse.
Now it's a new module.
And you can use that module to
build still new programs.
You can build a huge
power abstraction.
So for example, in the
figure-drawing program you can
actually write programs
that generate trees.
And then you can write
a five-line script.
And you say, OK, feed
that through my
tree-generating program.
And it'll make a tree that you
can use in your figures, in
your talks, or in your books.
So I'll post a few
examples of that.
The input as five-line tree
and the output PDF.
So the first time you write that
program it takes longer
than doing it graphically,
no question.
Which is why this second
part happens.
Because you do it the slightly
hard way the first time.
You don't realize the second
time you're like, oh, there's
something in common here.
[BUZZER SOUND]
But it's too late.
I just have to do it the
slightly hard way.
The third time you think, OK,
finally I'm going to do it
with the program.
So I think there are fundamental
reasons to think
that if you can program
your documents you'll
also be more efficient.
Now, that actually may end
up not being true.
I suspect it is.
But it may not be.
But even if it isn't take
it as not an absolute.
But as a suggestion to
try in your own work
and in your own writing.
And I don't mean it
as an absolute.
OK, so now there's 10
more questions.
But I'm going to leave
them for now.
And if at the end we haven't
used up all the time with
questions I'll continue with
some of those questions.